selon les données récentes de
statistique canada les prix des légumes
frais et des fruits également ont connu
une augmentation de 17 3% en juin vous
le voyez par rapport à l'an dernier
cette hausse est la plus marquée depuis
janvier 2016 on remarque déjà une hausse
entre mai et juin de cette année on en
parle avec sylvain charlebois les
professeurs à la faculté de management
et d'agriculture de l'université
dalhousie à halifax bonjour sylvain
bonjour la météo est souvent pointé du
doigt lorsqu'il est question d'augmenter
le prix des produits frais mais c'est
pas la seule responsable de ces aux noms
souvent quand on regarde quand on évalue
le prix de produits les légumes des
fruits dont il semble que les
changements climatiques ont le dos large
ces temps ci dans le cas du céleri dans
le cas de la lède su c'est vraiment une
question de production et de logistique
vous savez michel aux états unis il est
très difficile d'engager des camionneurs
le coût de transport est vraiment
explose ça coûte de plus en plus cher et
ce sont des produits périssables donc
dès que la récolte est effectué
il faut transporter ces produits là le
plus rapidement possible alors faut pas
attendre on peut pas attendre alors
c'est pour ça que ça que d'un petit peu
plus cher transporter ses produits donc
ça peut être une question de manque de
main d'oeuvre
de frais de manutention de douane entre
autres mais il n'y a pas également une
fluctuation qui les fait en fait de ne
pas pu l'arrêter de certains produits
ouais ben il ya certaines rumeurs qui
suggérerait que certains gourous
encourager les gens d'avoir du jus de
céder anthony williams notamment jeudi
le faisait sur youtube pendant plusieurs
mois
moi j'ai l'impression que c'est oui ça
peut-être cct une vague mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est vraiment a dû au
fait qu'il y avait un manque un manque
d'offre
d'ailleurs les choses se sont replacées
depuis quelques semaines la pour les
céleris entre autres pour les fans de
céleri et à des bloody six heures ça va
et moins cher maître la série dans votre
boulot d'ici juin la tête de série
talbot de dollars ben alors qu'elle a
connu des prix pas mal plus élevé bon
comme vous disiez certains accusés la
popularité de certains je dis nous
depuis le nouveau
bon je cherche le terme le nouveau guide
alimentaire merci guide alimentaire
canadien où on encourage les gens
vraiment à manger davantage de fruits
davantage de légumes est ce que ça a une
influence selon vous sur le prix de ses
produits
non mais la réalité c'est que le prix de
fruits et légumes mais et est très
volatile en on regarde juste que depuis
depuis que le guide alimentaire a été
présenté en janvier dernier les carottes
sont 30% plus cher les oignons 20% plus
cher les pâtes à 18 % plus cher donc en
gros on parle d'une augmentation qui
dépasse le 20 % de plus j'ai envie du
site pour ça depuis on est alors c'est
quand même assez important
si on encourager les canadiens à manger
plus de fruits et légumes
il faut s'assurer que ces produits là
deviennent beau trop cher pour la
famille moyens donc il va falloir
augmenter la capacité production ici
même au canada pour s'assurer qu'ils
aient moins de volatilité qui profitent
de l'augmentation de ses prix est ce que
ce sont les producteurs les
distributeurs mais en fait c'est c'la
semble de l'oeuvre finalement il faut
toujours faire de l'argent pour pourrait
tendre à faire c'est certain mais en
gros vous savez la distribution au skite
du maraîcher particulièrement les marges
sont très minces parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de gaspillage
ce sont des produits qui sont
périssables
il faut dire il faut tenir sa ligne de
compte là quand on évalue les niveaux de
preuve sa piscine à bout de ligne à
damas les constations de faire de
l'argent bowling et on doit charger plus
cher une faute d'entente et pour le
moment ça nous coûte un peu plus cher
justement quand on passe à la caisse
sylvain charlebois merci beaucoup au
revoir